and over time that corrupts
I think there has to be an introspection
in tech companies about the culture that
they develop about the um the political
ideology the bubble it's interesting to
see that bubble like I've um
ask myself
a lot of questions I've interviewed the
Pfizer CEO
um what seems now a long time ago
and I've gotten a lot of criticism uh
the positive comments but also criticism
from that conversation and I did a lot
of soul searching about the kind of
bubbles we have in this world and it
makes me wonder
pharmaceutical companies
they all believe
they're doing good
and I wonder
because the the idea they have is to
create drugs that help people and do so
at scale
and it's hard to know at which point
that can be corrupted it's hard to know
when it was corrupted and if it was
corrupted and where which which drugs
and which companies and so on
and I don't know I don't know that
complicated it seems like inside a
bubble you can convince yourself if
anything is good uh people inside the
the Third Reich regime were able to
convince themselves I'm sure many just
um bloodlands is another book I've been
really recently reading about it and the
ability of humans to convince they're
doing good when they're clearly
murdering and torturing people in front
of their eyes
is fascinating
they're able to convince themselves
they're doing good it's crazy
like there's not even a inkling of Doubt
um yeah I don't I don't know what to
make of that so um it has taught me to
be a little bit more careful when I
enter into different bubbles
to um
be skeptical about what's taken as an
assumption of Truth like you always have
to be skeptical about like what's
assumed is true is it possible it's not
true
um you know if you're doing if you're
talking about the America
uh it's assumed that uh you know in
certain places that surveillance is good
well let's let's question that uh that's
that assumption
um yeah and I also it inspired me to
question my own assumptions that I I
hold this true
constantly uh constantly it's tough it's
tough but you don't grow I mean do you
want to be just static and not grow you
have to question yourself on some of
these things if you want to grow as a
person
yeah for sure uh one of the tough things
actually of being a public personality
when you speak publicly is you get
attacked
all along the way as you're growing
right and
um uh in part a big softy as well if I
may say and those heart it hurts it
hurts it hurts do you pay attention to
it
yeah
um yeah yeah yeah it's very hard like I
have two choices one you can uh shut
yourself off from the world and ignore
it I've I never found that compelling
this kind of idea of like Haters Gonna
Hate yeah like uh
this idea that uh anyone with a big
platform or anyone's ever done anything
was always gotten hate you know okay
maybe but like I still want to be
vulnerable where are my heart and my
sleeve really show myself like open
myself to the world really listen to
people and that means every once in a
while somebody will say something that
touches me in a way that's like
what if they're right do you let that
hate influence you I mean can you be
bullied into a different opinion than
you think you really are just because of
that hate no no I believe not but
it hurts in a way that's hard to explain
like um
yeah it just it gets to like uh
it shakes your faith in humanity
actually is is probably why it hurts
like um
people that um
call me a Putin apologist or a zelensky
apologist which I'm currently getting
almost an equal amount of
but it hurts
it hurts because I
um it hurts because it like it it
damages slightly my faith in humanity to
be able to see
um
the love that connects us and then to
see that I'm trying to find that
and that's I'm doing my best in the in
the limited capabilities I have to find
that and so to call me something uh like
a bad actor essentially from whatever
perspective it just makes me realize
well
um people don't have empathy and
compassion for each other it makes me
question that for a brief moment and
that that's like a crack and it hurts
how many people do this to your face
thank you
uh very few yeah so it's online
e-muscles man they're just like I have
to be honest that uh it's it happens
yeah because I've hung around with uh
with Rogan enough
when your platform grows there's people
that will come up to Joe and say stuff
to his face
that they forget they they still
um they forget he's an actual real human
being
they'll they'll make accusations about
him so does that cause him to wall
himself off more no he's uh he's pretty
gangster on that but
um yeah it still hurts if you're if
you're human if you've really um
feel others I think that's also the
difference with with Joe and me he has a
his family that he deeply loves and
that's an escape from the world form
um there's a loneliness in me that's I'm
always longing to connect with people
and with like regular people and like
just to to learn their stories and so on
and so if you open yourself up that way
the things they tell you can really hurt